like it's like Michael Jordan and then
you go down to BJ Armstrong it's like oh
I've had but much times about Tony
Robbins how great he is and blah blah
blah like him a lot I got a lot of value
out of going to his workshop it was all
with you and I bet well because it
freaked me out
yeah and a lot of people get freaked out
of people's preconception is just this
is like a cult
this guy's a snake oil salesman or
whatever yeah like what am I getting
myself into and I gotta admit like when
I went there I was like okay cool I'm
going but I'm not doing any of that
dancing [__] I'm just uh I'm just here
for the information I'm gonna sit down
I'll be quiet I'm not gonna yell not
gonna hug I'm not gonna dance and he sat
separately so you wouldn't be
embarrassed if you do one with my
brother-in-law and we just agreed
beforehand we're like you know we might
end up doing the dancing [__] so you sit
on that side of the room I'm sitting on
this side of the room and let's see if
we didn't see each other except for at
the end of the night when the event
would end each day and we would get back
together but anyways by you know our one
I'm dancing and doing all the good stuff
too but anyways it was a lot of value
and you know it cost me like a thousand
bucks to go do this thing I thought a
tremendous and then in the thing like he
up smells just like this guy does right
so he's like you know one of the first
kind of I don't know coaches lifestyle
coaches business coaches out there and
he's been doing this for 40 years now so
he went from audio tapes to books to
infomercials now the internet like
whatever the channel was he wrote it and
was like I'm the business coach I'm the
lifestyle coach and you know I got a lot
of value and at one point he upsells his
business mastery class or his business
mastery thing is like okay if you like
this if you like how you're feeling
right now and right after he makes you
feel great he's like you know that table
over there
is for anybody who wants to grow their
business it's ten thousand dollars you
spent five days with me and if you don't
get a million dollars of value from this
thing I will give you all your money
back and in the moment I was like dude I
got a million dollars of value today you
know of course I would do that so I
didn't actually sign up for it but our
buddy see him it did and went to he did
it so I believe so and so you know sorry
see if I got that wrong but I'm pretty
sure he told me he did
and I have several friends who actually
did it as well and they said they're
like yeah it's great and if you have a
business that's doing you know if you
have a business your size right your
business is worth tens of millions of
dollars if you can get a sort of 2
percent 3 percent 5 percent lift yeah in
your business just through improving
your own psychology your own enthusiasm
your own tactics
it's obviously paid itself off right so
how does the infrastructure of this work
like I'm looking at it now does you just
Tony Robbins literally have to be at all
the things no so well he does his live
events yes so he's the Traveling
Salesman that does the live events and
he probably does I don't know I'm gonna
get it wrong but like let's call it 20
to 40 live events a year a lot that's a
lot you know every week he every week or
two he's somewhere and then he has his
sort of like army of like coaches that
are trained under him bit by the way
they all seemed garbage and so he has
this you know the people who are the
actual coaches I will call you and do
all this other stuff with you they are
you know like there's like a fleet of
them I don't know a hundred and hundred
people that and just need a common
structure is garbage those people are
garbage when I met them I was not
impressed in fact on the day's so tell
her I'm gonna do this for 40 years to
the point where he's been public
speaking on stages hype and crowds up
for like 40 years
right so he can't actually do two days
back-to-back so he does date one and it
goes from 8 a.m. till 1 a.m. and there's
no breaks yeah you can go to the
bathroom but you were missing the action
when you go it has just talked and the
whole time he's on stage he's talking
and he's got 10,000 people in an
audience I've been twice now I should
have been three times I just did that so
the first time I was just experiencing
it the second times I was observing it
because I took a fleet of friends I
bought tickets for my family and friends
I was like this is the best gift I can
give you and they loved it most of them
and so anyways he holds people's
attention for like 14 hours straight
which is incredible you know you can't
most people can't you know listen to a
six-minute YouTube video and have their
attention held but then the second day
it's not him on stage because his vocal
cords are shredded so he can't speak the
next day and this like his number two
comes up and this guy's a good public
speaker but he's not like it's like
Michael Jordan and then you go down to
BJ Armstrong and it's like
now I came here to Michael Jordan and so
literally this guy just he says stuff
and then he tees up a video of Tony
talking ten years ago when he used to do
this like he used to do all four days
himself oh my god he queues up the the
video of telling me and you sit there
and you're watching youtube videos with
ten two thousand other people and this
guy is just moderating it it's like this
bizarre experience that's crazy I didn't
really sell it very well but I'll tell
you this that was probably the best the
best money I've ever spent on anything
self-improvement wise if you add up all
the books or anything else it's not even
close maybe I should do it
you tell it you should totally do it I
took about 20 people so I paid for 20
people's tickets to go see gran yeah I
basically became an affiliate for him I
didn't get paid I just I believed in it
so much I paid for 20 other people to go
and since then and it's been four years
since then and of them I would say four
people were like me where they were like
a holy [__] life changed that was the
most valuable thing it's a 4 out of 20
let's say and then another let's call it
I don't know 15 were kind of like that
was amazing and I talked to him a year
later they're like disappointed in
themselves that they didn't carry it
forward they're like God it was so good
and I had so much clarity and I had so
much energy but I'm kind of mad at
myself I just kind of let it fade from
there like I don't really remember it
now I just remember what I felt then and
yeah I guess I didn't really get too
much value because I'm not doing any of
the things I wanted to do you know after
that weekend well and there's no three
or four people that literally left they
were like this is way too culty this is
pop science I don't like this I don't
believe this I don't like how he's
manipulating everybody I'm out and I was
like okay that's the spectrum anyone I
know um Alex from calm the founder of
calm he hated it and so he just went for
a bike ride I think in the middle of one
of the days because he was like it's
just too much for me he's like I don't I
didn't I didn't feel good and what was
going on and so I left I rode my bike
around the city and I had fun during
that
and what uh what was the number one
takeaway for me dude I have a notepad
full that I call the Bible because I was
like this is the closest thing that I
have to religion right it's like
religion and it smelled like God
religion is like an operating philosophy
for life right that's what that's what
people use religion for in many ways
like you know don't harm your neighbor
bla bla bla like it's an operating
philosophy so this was an operating
philosophy so I'll give you two of the
Nuggets right so the first one is the
quality of your life is equal to the
quality of the emotions you have on a
day-to-day basis so what is that mean
it's kind of a mouthful but like we're
both in a good position we're very
privileged or more successful than we
ever thought we would be seven years ago
probably like the position we're in now
seven years ago us would have been
envious at that but your happiness is
not like ten times more than it was
seven years ago right like you're
probably feeling about the same and the
reason why is that you know life is not
about you know what you have and what
you've achieved it's about who you've
become and so what most people what most
people miss is that if you are doesn't
matter if you're rich doesn't matter if
your family doesn't matter if you have a
you know if you're famous if the
emotions that you're feeling on a
day-to-day basis are stressed then you
have a shitty quality of life
if you're feeling anger or upset then
you have a shitty quality of life
regardless of everything else and so
then the question is how do you figure
out how to like change your emotions on
a day-to-day basis so you're feeling
good every day regardless of your
situation
it's the intent select so he gives you
three three you like tool he's like
alright here's the three ways you can
change how you feel the very first thing
is your butt is physical so if you
change your if you have a radical chains
and your physiology calls it which it
basically means if you did a bunch of
push-ups if you exercised if you ran if
you jumped into a cold pool or or why
people like taking out hot showers it's
relax
the fastest way to change how you feel
is to physically change your body in
fact Emmett who's the CEO twitch was
telling me the other day or he was kind
of talking about this on Twitter people
have panic attacks and when you have a
panic attacks really uncomfortable
feeling
and most people panic attacks really
want a solution of like how do I not get
these and I take medicine and
some people take medicine and that's one
way to change your physiology is
chemically changing your physiology what
most people try to do is like people try
to help people think their way out of it
they're like oh just know don't be so
anxious and you need to just relax I'm
like as if that can help
that's like best if that was that easy
yeah we would all do it and actually
what science has shown is that the
fastest most effective kind of quick and
dirty way to stop a panic attack is to
plunge your face into really cold water
if you do that right at the start of
panic attack it will stop it because
your fight-or-flight will kick in it'll
it'll override that and so one time I
one time I accidentally ate brownies at
my roommate made and they turn out to be
edible brownies and I don't smoke weed
and I hate weed so much like I don't do
any of that and I was like James I'm
flipping out he goes yeah I'm sorry
those were we brown and I I started
having a panic attack and I went and
gotten a cold shower and that was the
only thing that helps oh nice okay yes
so that's fastest way to change what you
feel is your body either through heat
cold or getting your heart rate up and
exercising and it doesn't be like go to
the gym it can be like if you did ten
jumping jacks you will feel different
than you did but right before that the
second one is focused so what are you
going to focus on so you you know where
you place your focus is gonna judge how
what your brain is what your brain is
basically signalling to your body of how
to feel so if you're focused on pain
then you're gonna feel shitty if you
focused on how somebody did you wrong
how this guy cut you off in traffic
you're gonna get outraged but if you
focus on things you're grateful for if
you focus on things are going well if
you focus on things that are that you
can trust that you can rely on you'll
feel different and then the last one is
I think it's like language so you
language your story which is basically
the words you use in the story you tell
yourself the big the big idea and I
recommend this to anybody who's in
business which is the quality of your
results is linked to your quality of
your decisions and the quality of your
decisions is linked to the quality of
the internal monologue you have so the
conversation you have with yourself ends
up dictating the decisions you make
which ends up dictating the
results you get and that's kind of what
I pulled away from the whole thing and
then it's all a bunch of strategies to
do that better I think you just saved me
a thousand dollars well you got to get
up and dance with the wise it's gonna
sting
this is awesome I like this yeah I
always hesitate to talk about it cuz
it's like I'm a preachy but no I don't
think it helps some people it's never
preachy when you can make fun of it so
like you you do a good job of making fun
of something and then you explain what
it is so that's never preachy
[Music]
you